hey guys welcome to the second episode
of flashback Friday today I will be
taking you through one of the most
popular and powerful programming
languages of all time Java with over
three billion devices running Java it
has helped shape the world as we know it
today so without further ado let's jump
in and learn some interesting facts
about the history of Java james gosling
and colleagues at Sun Microsystems
develop Java in the early 1990s this
team of engineers call themselves the
Green Team and initiated the project for
interactive television a typical example
of interactive television would be the
real-time voting on the screen in which
the user can control the show however
this technology was too advanced for the
industry and was better suited for the
world wide web Java was initially named
the green pop and then as Oh in 1994 it
was officially renamed to Java the first
public implementation was Java 1.0 in
1995 in 2006 some released java virtual
machine as a free and open source
software in the same year j2se was
renamed as java standard edition or SE
meteor releases involve Java SE 6 in
March 2006 and Java SE 8 in 2014 as of
today Java 8 and Java 11 are identified
as long-term support versions popular
Java based products like j-unit Eclipse
Hadoop and Android revolutionized the IT
industry the biggest internet company
google has a huge percentage of its
development in Java Accenture is using
Java for most of its clients have their
companies like Intel Symantec Philips
Thomson are all Java users Java is also
considered the official language for
Android gave development bug G the
latest youth obsession is a
cross-platform game that uses Java as a
source and language since 2007 Java has
remained a de facto standard and is
controlled through the Java community
process Java has evolved to become the
most popularly used language and
continues to make
double contribution into the field of
technology so that is all for today's
episode of flashback Friday this is your
host Shinmei signing off we will be back
with another technology in the next
episode until then keep learning and
stay tuned to simply learn
[Music]